but dorsa we have a very very special
guest
uh
from chess by the numbers ty has joined
us welcome welcome welcome
thank you it's great to be here i gotta
tell you up front ty we've never met but
i've been exploiting you for an entire
week i love your site i love your models
and your way of writing and explaining
to the audiences
uh
the uh
the winning percentages
and it's extraordinary that
after a single half of play
this most eagerly anticipated event it's
a near 98 certainty according to your
model
that uh napo or fabi will be the
challenger
so my narrative from the very beginning
of the tournament was that this is an
unpredictable tournament just about
anything could happen right and i'm
shocked that this happened
well put i think we all feel that way
yeah
yeah we all expected uh the unexpected
and right someone's gonna come out of
nowhere and instead just the two people
that have won it before are running away
with it
yeah
yeah dorsey questions for type so one of
my questions would be like do you take
like uh the whole game like would you go
over specific moves and compare them to
maybe engine moves or the expected moves
like do you go move by move or do you go
game by game result by result my model
is result by result um yeah so i've
always kept the model as simple as i can
because i want to make sure that people
can understand where the numbers are
coming from
my ultimate goal isn't necessarily to
predict chess as perfectly as possible i
want to come
close so that it means something but i
really want to provide that context for
understanding as much as possible about
what's going on in a tournament
for the fans so a simpler model makes
that easier i think
so i use just the players ratings uh
live writing
and put a win draw and lost percentage
on each game from
and treat all the games as independent
and just simulate out all the unplayed
games in the tournament see who won
simulate it again
add ad nauseam until i have a large
enough sample size to see who won the
most of those simulations wonderful all
right ty what we're going to do is we're
going to bring up on our
screen
the
percentage
where things stand after
six rounds and could you explain to us
why even though there's only a half a
point gap between fabi and yan yan is
almost
two to one favorite over fabi at this
exact moment and they have to play
uh they have a date with destiny in
round nine
that's going to be the huge game of the
tournament but
so the reason he's that big of a
favorite is because he's got that half
point lead um
one of the things i like about the model
is it helps us figure out how important
something like half a point is or isn't
when it might not be completely
intuitively clear right and what the
model is telling us is that a half point
is more than it feels like even with
seven rounds left the fact is he's ahead
so fabi has to outplay him in the second
half
and in fact if bobby wants to win
outright he has to outplay yon by a full
point over the final seven games
uh if they if if fabi outplays him by
half a point
they still have tie breaks and if they
play equal to each other through the
final seven games
yawns through so that's where that two
to one edge comes from
okay ty this is not going to be
intuitively obvious for our audience in
round seven
fabi
won
right
yep i know where you are and his
percentage went down
it did
whereas jan won and as you would expect
his percentage went up but went up
tremendously explain why
because of who they were playing uh fabi
was
supposed to have a good chance of
winning that game against timor
again yeah he had white against the
lowest rated player in the tournament
the model thought he was likely
relatively likely to win that game a
draw is always the most likely result of
a game but he had good winning chances
okay so his expected score for the
tournament didn't go up that much by
winning right yawn
won a tough game as black
he improved his expected score by more
so he gained and extended his lead in
that expected score at the end category
and all fabi's win was enough to do was
to keep pace
he did lose percentage even with a win
but keep in mind if he had drawn that
game he would have dropped to like 16
so the win was still way better than a
draw would have been it just wasn't good
enough to actually improve his odds
because the player ahead of him also won
he won but he still wasn't good enough
what else did you want from the guy
you wanted him to see you lose
there you go you
and we've actually seen that throughout
the tournament welcome tied to the
conversation where players go check out
the other opponent's boards and they're
disgusted by what they saw when nepo
checked out fabi's game against ali reza
and favi already had an extras exchange
nepal was cruising through duda he looks
at the game and just makes a grimace
like man this guy's still on my heels i
can't shake him off and yes absolutely
it does seem that favi is most important
to keep pace but nepo's result
especially with rapport with the black
pieces just catapults him in the numbers
i mean yeah that's that's why uh
why nepo's the two to one favorite on
half a point
like to if we wanted to go with an
extremely impossible example if they if
fabi could win his final seven games
we've seen him do it before
and it wouldn't be enough if nepo won
his last seven they play each other so
technically that's not possible say they
draw their game and win each win etc but
the point is bobby can win as much as he
wants but as long as nepo keeps winning
there's nothing he can do about it
um it's the thing about the round robin
or the double round robin format
you only play your opponent in two if
you're neck and neck with one other
player like this you only play them
twice and the other 12 games are against
other players and it's what you do
against those other players that'll
decide it
wonderful tai i
once again i just want to say thank you
so much for taking time out of your day
and joining us and once again i want to
say how much i personally enjoy your
site i love it i mean wake up in the
morning i go i like your
writing style and making it a very
simple to understand
how can
the chess world support your efforts
um
so i do have a paypal donation link on
my blog
[Music]
chessnumbers.wordpress.com
and
has that link i also have a patreon page
i will admit i do not post any
subscriber exclusive content i intend to
but it just doesn't happen
but it's still a way uh if you wanted to
subscribe there just to support the work
that i will keep doing there's that
other than that read the blog follow me
on twitter i do a lot of stuff that's
twitter only for smaller tournaments
the candidates all write 1500 words
every night and put out full articles
and all the explanations but for a lot
of other tournaments i'm still
calculating odds and i'll just tweet the
screenshots of those odds and leave it
at that so follow me on twitter at chess
numbers is a great place for a lot of my
content that isn't anywhere else
and
yeah just following and supporting is i
really appreciate it it means i can't
tell you how much it means to me to hear
you say that you're reading reading the
work i've been following you for ages
and you're just a huge inspiration for
me so i really appreciate it
and ages and ages and ages i get it i
get it todd thank you very much
but thank you for all the good work and
uh
really appreciate a question yeah i was
we were wondering um
well what are your experiences with
chess do you play regularly
i have been
an on and off chess player my whole life
i've always loved the game but whether
or not i'm playing it all has sort of
come in a couple waves
i've loved the game since i was seven i
inherited a huge chessbook collection
from my grandpa and
taught myself
to love the game from those books i
really never i read them like novels i
never really like studied them with a
board very much so i didn't actually get
that good but i
fell in love with the game uh when i was
17 i found the concept of tournament
chess for the first time played for a
couple played a few tournaments over
those couple years then lost some
interest
then came back in my late 20s and got
involved in tournaments again the last
tournament i played was in 2014. i got
my rating up over 1500.
and i'm actually
pretty sure this summer i'm going to be
back over the board for the first time
again i've been doing a lot of study at
home over the last year or so and i'm
hoping that i've improved and that i can
go prove it
well go get em tiger and again thank you
so much for uh joining the conversation
absolutely thank you cheers
nice nice that's chess by the numbers uh